it's a familiar premise we've all seen
hundreds and hundreds of movies whether
it's the marvel movies or james bond
they all get to a point where the
world's about to end and i just think
narrative is really powerful and in some
ways maybe we all think as not only
people but as audience members that it's
just going to work out you know there's
there's this kind of tradition of
using love as a theme for something more
than just two people kissing so
i guess on some level that's what we're
trying here it's a mistake i think for a
filmmaker to pursue themes you know in
his this is a mistake i think i i think
themes have to emerge from a story that
is uh based in in fact i loved how the
story kept evading your best
expectations and bringing it home in a
way that felt true
and um
yet surprising which is i think the best
quality of a great story and so one of
the things that i do is to write
backstories for my characters and
actually i have some of these
backstories acted out by the actors
themselves because by actually acting
out the backstory it doesn't become just
ideas and thoughts but in fact it
becomes memory and experience there i i
had an appetite for that book and i
wanted the people who had loved the book
as much as i did
will find some respect for
of the world of the poetry of the book
in the same time i wanted my mother to
understand the movie i wanted to
to the people that don't know nothing
about this world will feel welcome i
think it's it's um inherently dramatic
to tell the truth about something but in
particular to tell the truth about
something you're not supposed to talk
about you know to tell the truth about
something taboo one thing i told myself
in this was that i wouldn't try
too hard to ape the brilliance of my
former colleagues but what i would try
and do was not second guess my instinct
the real goal was to sort of um and i
think i'm at this time in my life you're
grateful for your experience but you
really want to let your imagination to
be as free as you can it felt to me
more dramatic to focus the story on
the time in their family's life when
when
all the chips were on the table it was
important to me that these characters
are flawed and
messed up and not defined by
their deafness
[Music]
[Music]
i started just talking to a lot of
people and scientists and i kept looking
for good news
and i never
got it everything i was hearing was
worse than what i was hearing on the
mainstream media and so i was talking to
a buddy of mine who's a journalist david
sirota
and we were both just like can you
believe that this isn't being covered in
the media that it's being pushed to the
end of the story there's no headlines
and sirota just off-handedly said uh
it's like a comet's headed to earth and
no one it's going to destroy us all and
no one cares and i just was like that's
the idea
and what i liked about it was it's a
familiar premise we've all seen hundreds
and hundreds of movies whether it's
you know towering inferno or the marvel
movies or james bond they all get to a
point where the world's about to end and
they all work out just fine
and i just think narrative is really
powerful and in some ways maybe we all
think as not only people but as audience
members that it's just gonna work out
it's um
interesting how love challenges us when
it comes to defining ourselves and i
think a lot of the films that i've made
up until now deals a lot with
sense of identity and loss and who are
who am i and at this stage in life and
so forth and so in this film i wanted to
kind of make a story about a young
person julie she's about to turn 30 and
she's kind of lost in the situation
where she doesn't know how to
appreciate herself and she doesn't know
how to figure out her love life and i
there's a tradition in cinema that's
dealing with love it's an existential
question if you look back at george coo
course wonderful films from the 30s and
40s or eric romer now that we are in
france you know there's there's this
kind of tradition of using love as a
theme for something more than just two
people kissing so
i guess on some level that's what we're
trying here it's a mistake i think for a
filmmaker to
to um pursue themes you know in his this
is a mistake i think i i think themes
have to emerge
from a story
that is uh based in in fact
uh
that has uh that is entertaining to an
audience
and that hopefully has comedic and
dramatic possibilities the themes um
have to grow quite naturally from that
you know i i it's sort of
i remember hearing about people that
were songwriters that would think oh you
know i used to have to sit down and try
and write a hit song right they wanted
to write like a hit song and they said
that oh just they could never do it
right and then if they were lucky enough
to have a hit song they just happened to
be like sitting at breakfast one morning
buttering their toast
and something came into their mind and
they and they and they wrote it
um i think this is a it's a more
organic way to work but i really as i
know you do i really really really enjoy
working with writers so when you when
you work with your crit chris white is
in your michael greens and you know
scott franks and people like this these
are very very impressive
wordsmiths and
the way you know the way the way they
handle story and um and then this sort
of balance and for me to answer your
question in terms of a sort of um
jumping off point uh was trying to
absorb
uh what you learned from people like
that they're the fantastic uh
understanding of the grammar of film
particularly certain kinds of genres and
how the sort of the the mechanics of
those work but then they always know and
this is
where i sort of left off when to sort of
try and let it fly one thing i told
myself in this was that
i wouldn't try and
too hard to ape the brilliance of my my
former colleagues but what i would try
and do was not second guess my instinct
about um
a certain kind of irishness that i
suppose is in the writing i sometimes
it's episodic or maybe it's always
episodic and stream of consciousness-y
or it's full of vivid moments but i
didn't i didn't worry too much about
those things i remember as a younger
filmmaker and all the inciting incident
has to be on page 20 and you know the
the big thing needs to happen the end of
the first act and then you need to
recalibrate something i let that go and
uh try to
um capture even if it wasn't direct sort
of spirit of things like the way my
grandfather
uh spoke who did quote bit of poetry
from time to time and kieran hines does
get to quote a bit of yates yes and um
and so uh the real goal was to sort of
um and i think i'm at this time in my
life
you're grateful for your experience but
you really want to let your imagination
to be as free as you can so when it was
brought to me it was always kind of
through the lens of richard but i felt
like that
was really an interesting way to to tell
this story because i think we all know
what venus and serena go on to have gone
on to achieve in their in their lives
but
it felt to me
more dramatic to focus the story on
the time in their family's life when
when
all the chips were on the table and that
there was a real
um precarious situation of whether or
not this huge gamble that they had made
as a family was gonna work and that that
window
seemed to me the
the most dramatic and it really
distilled their journey down to
something that was you know was a movie
but the thing is that uh i will state
the obvious the idea was that uh it was
important for me to uh honor honor the
dream that when i read the book to try
there i i had an appetite for that book
and i wanted the people who had loved
the book as much as i did
will find some respect for uh of the
world of the poetry of the book
in the same time i wanted my mother to
understand the movie i wanted to to uh
to the people that don't know nothing
about this world will feel welcome
and
so to balance
uh information there are so many
cultures so many tribes in this in this
um to to find the right balance so to
give enough you know it's like
and not
put uh
too much uh an exposition at the
beginning
that
that would crush the other the aliens
would feel crushed under the the
hamilton for information that was that
was probably the the
the forming the main challenge i would
say that at the beginning of the book
the books start by saying uh some
something like uh beginnings are very
delicate times and i will see that
definitely
how to open this movie was the the big
challenge how to approach it at the
beginning we try to be more faithful to
the book and realize quickly that not
quickly not quickly we realize at one
point after a lot of work that we had to
deviate a little bit
uh from the book in order to make a
softer a more gentle introduction to the
world so people will have enough
in their
enough knowledge to not feel lust
at the beginning
i just found that the story kind of
really flowed in in a very interesting
different way between the four
characters and then when finally um phil
and peter start to get close and that
excludes rose and
worries her and
you know like
obviously phil is a character not to
take literally with you know when he
appears to want to make friends with
peter he could be very dangerous in many
different ways you know
um
and she has every reason to be
suspicious i think and but you know
i loved how the story kept evading your
best expectations
and bringing it home in a way that felt
true
and um
yet surprising
which is i think the best quality of a
great story what's so beautiful and
immersive about this film
are the reflective moments with the
characters and it's so nice to think
about what the characters are thinking
about you're capturing the actors
thoughts
when working with the actors did you
have a particular process in place that
gave them
the tools to color in the gray spaces
if the audience is able to keep watching
and can continue to feel something even
though the actors themselves are not
speaking i think that's really because
the actors themselves are feeling
something when they're playing those
roles they're not just standing there
they're feeling something but they're
not just doing what they were told but
they are in fact living their own
interpretations of the characters in
front of the camera i realized though
that this is a very difficult task and
so as a director i want to do my best at
helping them get to that place and so
one of the things that i do is to write
back stories for my characters and
actually i have some of these
backstories acted out by the actors
themselves because by actually acting
out the backstory it doesn't become just
ideas and thoughts but in fact it
becomes memory and experience we acted
out the relationship between kafuku and
otto and their relationship as a couple
and to have that memory be physicalized
for this to become physical memory i
think can be of help for the actors
especially in these quiet moments when
they don't necessarily have things to
say i think their body can actually help
because their body remembers acting out
these pasts
i knew i wanted to try to adapt this
book and that i could do totally
privately in my room no one has to see
it unless i want them to but i did need
the rights and so i i appealed to
ferrante the um author for the rights
and she's anonymous so there's no way to
communicate with her except by email so
i write to her and i said i want to
direct it i did say that
and i want to adapt it and i told her
not how i was going to adapt it because
at that point i really didn't know but i
told her why i wanted to adapt it which
i can tell you if you want but but i
so what i told her was i said okay her
book
is so honest i mean that's the thing
that's so compelling about it i think
it's it's um inherently dramatic
to tell the truth about something yes
but in particular
to tell the truth about something you're
not supposed to talk about you know to
tell the truth about something taboo
even like in a room if you're like let
me tell you something it's a scene
everybody leans in
and and that's exactly what she was
doing right she's talking about the
experience of being a woman in the world
in a way that i had never heard
expressed before secret things where
you're like holy [ __ ] i cannot believe
you said that out loud i'm i'm a little
freaked out and i'm
electrified and comforted to know i'm
not the only one who has like you know
perverse
dark feelings
yeah
yeah
and
so i said to
her wouldn't it be interesting if
instead of all of these people having
this experience reading your novels
alone in our rooms
where in some ways it still remains a
secret
these truthful things that she's putting
out there what if we could put it on a
screen what if we could actually hear
these things spoken out loud in a
communal space
where you might be sitting next to your
husband or your
mother or your daughter or your lover
whatever
and have to sit next to them and hear
these things out loud i was like well
that would be really radical then the
cat's really out of the bag then you
cannot put it back in you know
so
and so she said to get back to your
first question she said yes you can have
the rights
but only if you direct it
you know you talked about the the
mom-daughter relationship it's like it
was important to me that these
characters
are flawed and
messed up and not defined by
their deafness so like
jackie is a narcissist like she doesn't
say if i was blind would you want to
paint because
she's deaf and she's hurt you know i
think it's coming out of pure
narcissism of like well you are clearly
a teenager who's doing everything in
reaction to me
and the only reason you would be
pursuing something is
as a [ __ ] you to me so i think there's
just a kind of interesting
coming of age for everyone in the movie
um that the parents have to evolve and
grow up as well
you